c'est les films sont sexuelle c'est
parce que c'est là c'est dans la vie je
vais bien pour lui j'y tiens ça à coeur
alors c'est on est plus facilement
blessés c'est pas comme les autres
matches en scène qui sait de manoeuvre
est le truc qui me connaît nos idées
mais non tu es toi marche pas comme ça
on n'est pas dans le vide des idées je
sais pas quoi faire mais il est il
il a raison even différents personnages
yves surtout pas les facilités ou des
gestes que j'utilisais une habitude il
veut - est vu par lui
[Applaudissements]
deux choses que j'ai effleuré quand la
peinture architecture la musique
de fait il est inimitable sage dans son
danseur chansons dans l'est dans le
livre qu'il est en train d'écrire dans
ce film je crois pas que quelqu'un
d'autre et les mêmes choses de moi
peut-être autre chose mais pas la même
chose due
[Musique]
c'est des films sont sexuelle c'est
parce que c'est là c'est dans la vie
c'est le film lave va peut-être faire
une choc parce que je crois que tous les
gens qui va avoir rejeté des [ __ ] pour
être les pauvres malades ou je sais pas
quoi
je crois qu'ils vont sortir de l'oeuf il
meurt quand même touché parce que les
critères sont touchantes
ils vont pas être choqué je crois pas
mais ils vont être doublées je crois
tout le monde est un peu bisexuels la
chanson s'est terminée où ça va
continuer un garçon électrique
[Applaudissements]
je crois que le suivi du chivas et c'est
la peinture un peu d'art cinétique à
turnhout projet de chance de l'image
holloway
[Musique]